[Music]
foreign
ly any other topic is as hotly debated
among potterheads as the adaptation of
JK Rowling's Harry Potter book series
after the last appearances of Daniel
Radcliffe Emma Watson and Rupert Grint
in the movie series Almost 12 years ago
there is now news about a reboot in a
special format according to various
Hollywood media reports talks are
currently being held about an HBO series
based on the seven Harry Potter books
the idea is to produce a separate season
for each of the books this would make it
much easier to cover more of the details
of the original books which have only
been marginally touched upon in the
previous films or not at all this would
mean that seven seasons of the world
famous Harry Potter Saga would be
planned from the outset this is
naturally also associated with certain
risks especially if the series is not as
well received as anticipated actually
the idea has been circulating behind the
scenes for several years but it is said
to have been put on the back burner for
a while after the merging of Warner
Brothers and Discovery now that the deal
has been finalized last year however
production seems to be picking up pace
once again CEO David saslav has already
announced that he intends to make some
Harry Potter projects a top priority in
the future Creator JK Rowling is also
expected to play an important role in
the new projects and act as a producer
so far there is no official statement on
the Harry Potter series as soon as
further details come to light we will
let you know of course we are
particularly curious about the cast fans
will be Keen to know who will be
following in the footsteps of their
Movie heroes
thank you
[Music]